hahaha is there broccoli in my tea
that's that has lots of friends no look
I did my hair and makeup and then I
didn't put pants on so time to review
some red carpet fashions the Oscars have
happened okay they are literally
finishing up right now it's 8:46 p.m. I
am pickups sure breathing like when
you're trying to walk but then all of a
sudden your body's like what if we try
to jump rope while we walk I haven't
watched a single second of the Oscars
tonight I don't know who hosted it don't
know who want anything I don't know what
political statements have been made I'm
only here to review the red carpet
fashions if it's a red carpet I don't
know caveat I don't know we're going to
talk about fashions that's what this
channels always been about let's do it
let's review the red carpet fashions at
the Academy Awards aka the Oscars I'm
already out of breath trying to give out
all the caveats of the things that I
will miss but you know on top of all
this I won't know people's names I won't
probably talk about the people you want
me to talk about we're all just trying
our best Emily Blunt look at you you
look like the Cinderella of Kleenex
tissue you look like you're being
strangled by whimsy and tulle I think
that this is cute but also ah this is
very like Fern Gully meets militia woman
yeah now Street
you look like Mill Street this looks
like Canal Street in the most mail
Street cosplay at Mill Street I've ever
seen you look demure but you look like
with me this is one ageless sexy
librarian who's got her glasses on
because she's about to read you for film
and you know what those glasses don't
even matter her vision is ten ten ten
out of ten red fur fill will do again
you am a stone this is satin on satin on
satin pantsuit you're making it easy for
yourself when you pee you're making it
very difficult on yourself when you sit
down because that's that and it's gonna
dope you're gonna be your own personal
slip and slide which for you is probably
great people would expect nothing less
let's just doing bits you Nicole Kidman
im blue dabu di Bao but then also these
hips don't lie
these hips are like a 2019 Honda Element
that a family is gifting their child
that's about to go off to college with
put a bow on it
God's gift yeah dear C Ronan some people
think the front door is got its gift
others think the back door is God's gift
so this looks like there's a fire drill
at the fabric factory and you stop drop
rolled in whatever bubblegum satin was
next to you and then they made it work
you look demure and bubblicious yeah
Jennifer Lawrence this looks like
Shakira meets Jenai at Twain meets like
sexy lady and waiting meets like gender
curious knight of the round table
is great covers a lot of cultures covers
a lot of eras you yeah Sally Hawkins I
love you David water I thought you're
fantastic and I love this like high
bridge space Trojan Romanesque boudoir I
got invited to a key party but couldn't
decide on the era that I was showing up
in 70s 80 sixties 20 but I'm here and
I'm ready for whatever yeah Maya Rudolph
I like this
cuz I like you and this is handmade
stone right this is my handmaids talents
or this is just like 60 Steve Jobs to me
it's like tube of lipstick either way I
like all of it yeah Octavia Spencer
she's the queen of Emerald City and
that's it and we should be so lucky cute
y'all good oh yeah go done with your
silver self you look like I'm nickels it
wants to be I mean that in a cute way
and I'm very let's just very grungy
Great Gatsby it also looks like she's
waiting for her lover in a way like
you've got chainmail yeah Sandra Bullock
what who challenged you to make a sexy
ass Oscars dress out of something Burt
Reynolds Wrap that what Thanksgiving
turkey was cooked on you look good in
everything
yeah Lupita Nyong'o I know I'm the
saying her name incorrectly I think
she's absolutely wanting wanting
wonderful and stunning she looks like
she won some award for being the best
new updated version of the Statue of
Liberty she represents both freedom
aspirations all of that and she looks
insanely beautiful damn it armie hammer
army I have very big respect for you I
have met I have very big respect I have
I have a very big respect for you
Tiffany Haddish
stop it stop just stop it purely just
stop being the best that's it Timothy
sha'lame when did you become the sexiest
cater waiter and/or limousine driver
that has ever existed
zendaya what was the theme of the Oscars
gods and goddesses because the [ __ ] is
going on
Margot Robbie I don't even care that you
put some clearance rack target
Christmas garland over this super spelt
simple white gown you look great it's a
Festivus for the rest of us Jennifer
Garner I mean this is a compliment but
this looks like a stepmom scorned that
sashing in the room full blue and the
only thing that's left in the room that
is blue our balls get it girl yeah I own
the Davis when are we going to prove it
there is not only a Benjamin Button but
there is a Bethenny button that also
ages backwards and it is
Viola Davis yeah taraji P Henson goth
pixie really you come bearing this goth
nymph pixie Grecian woodland fairy
mythological figure and we're all just
supposed to be okay with it yeah I'm
okay with it you're Angelica BDSM nymph
pixie goddess and I it's beautiful Gina
Rodriguez what stop it stop it stop
looking like an elegant as parachute
stop it Salma Hayek okay well okay
Allison Williams you look like a dusty
goddess and I love it cute
Adam rip on your era harness the Oscars
and it couldn't be more symbolic because
us
truly taking a hold of all of our hearts
they're strapped in and they're riding
the atom rep on ride yeah well there you
go there's my quick analysis of the red
carpet fashions from the Oscars slash
Academy Awards let me know you guys
thought I know I missed a ton of people
that you probably wanted me to talk
about if you like them and I missed them
put them in the comments down below
also do not forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel click the bell
notification so you know when videos go
live because I want to say it's Tuesday
and Thursday but uh nights like this
days like this it's a little bit
different other than that I don't know
you're too good I can't meet you you're
too good I just have to be inspired by
you and you're doing it you you look
like a Jesus candle that I want a light
to clear out all the ghosts and demons
in my house and I want just your
radiation thanks bye